[Musique]
je m'excuse je m'excuse pour toutes ces
fois où je n'étais qu'un profane mais où
j'ai pris plaisir à faire le hooligan
[Musique]
ans
je m'excuse d'en avoir longtemps été
très ignorants
et de n'avoir comprimons hooliganisme
que trop récemment depuis j'essaie
d'être toujours conscient de mes
motivations et j'évite constamment de
chercher à uniquement prouver mes
convictions je me suis aussi donné la
mission de lutter contre les excès
d'irrationalité irresponsable j'espère
que mes vidéos aideront à prendre
conscience de notre hooliganisme
incontrôlable mais avant d'aller plus
loin je veux revenir sur un point je
m'excuse je m'excuse pour toutes ces
fois où je n'étais qu'un profane mais où
j'ai pris plaisir à faire le hooligan
[Musique]
j'ai si souvent gueuler plus fort
qu'autrui dans l'espoir que seule ma
position reste à l'esprit
j'ai si souvent utilisé les attaques
personnelles
pour suggérer que mon argumentation
était plus belle j'ai si souvent joué
sur la connotation des mots pour que
tous contre arguments se met à sonner
faux j'ai si souvent utilisé mes petites
histoires anecdotiques comme si elle
prévalait sur des conclusions des
science empirique
j'ai si souvent profiter de l'ignorance
de mes interlocuteurs pour passer pour
l'expert contraint de jouer au
vulgarisateur j'ai si souvent abusé de
sarcasme et de moquerie pour que toute
opposition et l'air d'une ânerie
j'ai si souvent fondées mais discours
sur des sophismes fallacieux pour gagner
le coeur des autres et devenir
victorieux j'ai si souvent akessé et
renchéri sur l'avis de la majorité pour
que mon ego surdimensionné gagne en
popularité
j'ai si souvent ignoré tous les
arguments des camps opposés au point
d'être incapable de m'en souvenir et de
les énoncer
j'ai si souvent éternuer de mauvais
article est de piètre émission juste
parce que ces travaux journalistiques
conforté mes convictions je m'excuse je
m'excuse pour toutes ces fois où je
n'étais qu'un profane mais où j'ai pris
plaisir à faire le hooligan mais avant
que vous me condamnez je vous invite à
prendre le temps de considérer les
causes de mon inacceptable excès de
confiance et de mon ignorance de
l'étendue de mon ignorance
[Musique]
à l'école j'ai eu le malheur d'être bons
étudiants les bonnes notes m'ont fait
croire que j'étais un savant je me suis
cru plus intelligent que les autres
crétins
j'ai fini par croire que j'étais un être
surhumain
[Musique]
mais le pire c'est une fois en école
d'ingénieur ou j'ai cru avoir été
sélectionnés parce que je faisais partie
des meilleurs la direction de l'école
n'arrêtait pas de dire qu'on était
l'élite de la nation des vingt ans j'ai
eu le sentiment de ne pas avoir besoin
de davantage de formation
[Musique]
on parlait déjà de nos futures grandes
responsabilités le grand défi était
devenue la maîtrise de l'art de
commander cet art repose en particulier
sur l'assurance et la confiance en soi
c'était déjà fini le temps où je pouvais
encore douter de moi
l'hésitation et l'incertitude était
devenu des signes de faiblesse pour
faire carrière
il me fallait maintenant mettre
l'adversaire en pls mes études
chlorifiée laert gagner des débats y
compris lorsque celui ci nécessite
d'user de coupat j'ai ainsi appris à
manipuler l'auditoire et ses émotions
pour que puissent triompher mes propres
convictions
je m'excuse
[Musique]
je m'excuse pour toutes ces fois où je
n'étais qu'un profane mais où j'ai pris
plaisir à faire le hooligan j'ai ensuite
vite appris l'importance de tisser un
vaste réseau professionnel de
connaissances or ce que valorise ses
connaissances et bien souvent l'excès de
confiance
nos concitoyens attendent souvent de
nous qu'on s'informe sur l'actualité et
que l'on dispose d'opinion tranchée
concernant tout débat de société
la plupart admire ceux qui ont des
principes et des convictions et qui
seront amenés à les éternuer à la
première occasion
pour être acceptée et intégrée à
différentes communautés leur
hooliganisme il me fallait à la fois
acceptée est adopté pire encore me
répétait ton pendant mon instruction
il faut parler au fort et avec
conviction
ce n'est qu ainsi que l'on peut monter
dans la hiérarchie pour diriger mieux
vaut ne pas jouer les introvertis les
incentives me poussèrent à embrasser mon
excès de confiance et a complètement
ignoré l'étendue de mon ignorance et je
n'ai pas eu besoin de penser mais
incentives pour ce faire pour mon
inconscient les incentives était tout à
fait clair c'est ainsi qu'à mon insu je
suis devenu hooligans politique et que
j'ai abandonné petit à petit mon esprit
critique
je m'excuse je m'excuse pour toutes ces
fois où je n'étais qu'un profane mais où
j'ai pris plaisir à faire le hooligan
pendant longtemps je n'en avais pas
conscience
je ne savais pas pourquoi je pense que
je pense
étrangement c'est en prenant de
lointaines vacances que je me mis enfin
apercevoir l'étendue de mon ignorance
c'est en partant en afrique en asie et
aux etats unis
je me rendis compte que mes préjugés
était pourri mieux encore les cultures
des pays à l'autre bout de la planète me
firent découvrir à quel point mon
intuition était malhonnête
tel un hooligan il me prenait l'envi de
tout critiquer même lorsque mon
intuition tranché n'avait rien de mieux
à proposer
pire encore je me rendis compte que ma
raison s'empressait alors à uniquement
justifier mon intuition
j'avais découvert ce phénomène appelé la
rationalisation qui montre que les
convictions repose souvent sur de
piètres fondation je m'excuse je
m'excuse pour toutes ces fois où je
n'étais qu'un profane mais où j'ai pris
plaisir à faire le hooligan
dans mon parcours j'ai aussi eu la
chance inouïe de tomber amoureux des
maths et de leurs bizarreries je
découvris ainsi le paradoxe de banhars
tarski ou encore l'existence de
plusieurs tailles d'infini mais le plus
marquant fut l'existence de plusieurs
logiques et par conséquent celle de
plusieurs univers mathématiques
j'aurais juré que la somme des
puissances de 2 est infini ou que tout
ensemble est nécessairement fini ou
infini
je découvrais que malgré tout ma rigueur
mathématique
j'étais en flagrant excès de confiance
et j'ignorais complètement l'étendue de
mon ignorance y compris dans un domaine
aussi basiques que la logique
je m'excuse
je m'excuse pour toutes ces fois où je
n'étais qu'un profane
mais où j'ai pris plaisir à faire le
hooligan j'aimerais pouvoir dire que je
l ai compris tout seul comme un grand
à l'aide de méditation et de mon cerveau
si brillant mais ceci n'est
malheureusement absolument pas le cas
c'est grâce à l'aide précieuse de
nombreux génies que je me suis tiré de
ce mauvais pas j'ai eu la chance de
découvrir d'incroyables youtuber nota
bene syllabus et le réveilleur science
étonnante y penser et el jj stupide
economics politiken et monsieur fille la
tronche-en-biais mycélium et eurêka
dirty biology hygiène mentale et langues
de chat vie sauce veritas y sommes et
smart aurait vu des voeux good stuff
course que acte et s'est dit pigrée
la linguistique l'histoire et l'économie
mort ont retourné le cerveau temps de
fait qui m'était cher se trouvèrent être
faux enfin un tech prem reconnaître
coupable et a considéré que mon
organisme était inexcusable
je m'excuse
je m'excuse pour toutes ces fois où je
n'étais qu'un pro fun mais où j'ai pris
plaisir à faire le hooligan
le génie de ces youtuber ce qu'il ya de
plus magique c'est qu'il me donnait
envie de lire les grands scientifiques
je me mis à dévorer les oeuvres de chai
ling et de rares harry celle de mesquita
ait taleb et kahneman et celle de shaw
carole caplanne ou encore prennent à
tous et brion livre insiste sur
l'étendue de notre ignorance et petit à
petit enfant chou mesuraient l'ampleur
de mon excès de confiance
je découvris aussi les limites de la
méthode scientifique et ses déviances et
je découvris le bail à nice mme et ses
étonnantes conséquences ce fut un très
long parcours du combattant
mais aujourd'hui enfin je pense
commencer à entrevoir à quel point je
suis ignorant
mieux encore j'ai découvert qu'il y
avait un énorme plaisir à savoir qu'il
me reste encore tant de choses à
découvrir
c'est aujourd'hui avec un énorme sourire
que je découvre mes erreurs
car c'est en décortiquant leur cause que
je progresse et devient meilleur
désormais conscient d'une partie de
l'étendue de mon ignorance je ressens le
devoir moral de répéter ceci avec
insistance je m'excuse
je m'excuse pour toutes ces fois où je
n'étais qu'un profane
mais où j'ai pris plaisir à faire le
hooligan
j'avais enfin à parler d'eux
wikipedia et michel bernard parmi
d'autres parmi vous pour remarquer que
wikipedia était en pleine quelques
saisons n'hésitez pas à donner de
l'argent à wikipédia et ce qui est vrai
de wikipédia est vrai aussi de beaucoup
d'excellents youtuber pas mal de trucs
vraiment fou sur le web finalement
requiert votons pour voir fonctionner
n'entre pas dans le cadre de l'économie
de marché classique
romain miller fait remarquer que en fait
la société d'aujourd'hui est déjà très
et pistes aux pratiques c'est vraiment
le point qu'il faut retenir c'est ce que
j'avais essayé de mettre en avant dans
les réponses commentaires de la vidéo
précédente
au final il ya énormément de décision en
fait toutes les décisions techniques
aujourd'hui ne sont pas démocratiques et
ne sont pas soumises en référendum est
souvent toutes ces décisions seront
finalement prise par des comités
d'experts et ne passe pas par la voie
classique de la politique pour
particuliers voie de recrutement royal
qui est le corps des mines le bluetooth
qui est encore des hauts fonctionnaires
qui recrute des ingénieurs notamment
dans les grandes écoles d'ingénieurs
françaises
tous ces gens vont être amenés à avoir
des postes très importants et à prendre
des décisions très importantes qui
seront finalement assez peu influencé
par l'opinion démocratique et même sans
aller jusque là juste parce que les gens
qui ont plus d'argent vont souvent plus
vous votez et corrélation entre le fait
d'avoir beaucoup d'argent et le fait
d'aller voter et plus généralement ceux
qui sont militants et qui on va voir le
plus de pouvoir en fait pour influencer
les décisions finales sont souvent des
versions plus informés que l'électeur
médian et sassou nguesso brennan ce
n'est pas une faiblesse de nos systèmes
politiques mais c'est même une force et
les selon brennan c'est ce qui explique
pourquoi nos systèmes démocratiques se
comporte finalement beaucoup mieux que
ce que l'on pourrait attendre d'une
démocratie selon brennan encore une fois
leurs romans miller me demande comment
je me positionne par rapport à tout ça
bah ça dépend des sujets ça dépend des
domaines pense qu'il ya des domaines où
avoir l'opinion démocratique qui dit son
mot saha le avantage au moins de donner
plus de capital moral à la société
puisque on aura alors une certaine
cohésion de la société sur d'autres
questions plus techniques ou l'opinion
de lecteurs médian est pas forcément
pertinente
c'est peut-être pas une si mauvaise
chose plus généralement et j'ai bien
peur que le prennent soin très très
compliqué que ça soit vraiment en
fonction des tifs
en question qu'on se pose j'ai bien
l'impression qu'il ya certaines
questions pour lesquelles la solution
démocratique et même souhaitable mais il
ya d'autres situations pour lesquelles
la situation et piste aux pratiques et
davantage souhaitable pour prendre un
exemple concret aujourd'hui je pense
qu'il ya beaucoup beaucoup trop de
discussions autour du terrorisme qu'ils
s'adoraient beaucoup plus être une
question d'experts parce que la
population est sourd très très très très
mal informée pirc ignorante sur des
questions comme le tourisme qui sont
émotionnellement très attachant sur
lesquels il ya beaucoup d'informations
des médias qui est pas forcément
toujours de très bonne qualité
bien sûr ça ce n'est qu'un exemple parmi
d'autres pourrait aussi citer la
vaccination ou tout ce qui est
régulation des marchés économiques vite
la question de savoir qu'est ce qu'il
faut avouer qu'il faut pas réguler c'est
une question très très très technique et
je pense que la bonne réponse pour la
plupart d'entre nous tout cas pour moi
c'est d'affirmer encore une fois que on
et ont souvent en excès de confiance et
qu'on ignore l'étendue de notre
ignorance et devant ce constat il nous
faut faire attention à ne pas nous
exprimer quand on ne sait pas assez pour
ne pas polluer le débat public
ceci pour ça que je censure pas mal de
commentaires que je trouve négatif pour
la réflexion de la plupart d'entre nous
souvent c'est une bonne chose de laisser
un espace de discussion qui soit aussi
propre que possible et dans lequel il ya
seulement les bonnes idées qui émergent
et pas tous pleins d'idées disparates
peu structurée et peut justifier
voilà qui amène au commentaire de i4i
chi qui fait remarquer qu'en fait sur
wikipédia sépare entièrement une lépi
stockera ci puisque d'une certaine
manière les personnes les plus actives
sur wikipédia auront plus de pouvoir
d'édition non je suis pas en train de
dire que wikipedia applique stricto
sensu une piste au cra ci parce que ça
voudrait dire d'être stricto sensu une
piste au cra si ce que j'essayais de
dire dans la vidéo précédente c'est que
finalement ce à quoi ou wikipedia
ressemble a été influencé par des
personnes qui auront tous de savoir et
que d'une certaine manière
le système de wikipédia implémente
version au moins faible de ce qu'on
pourrait appeler les pistes au cra 6
c'est à dire lorsque les personnes
savent elles ont plus de pouvoir
d'affecter l'issue des choses en
l'occurrence ici le contenu d'une page
wikipedia en particulier dans l'exemple
que donne
ik torchis apparemment une certaine
contributrice qui est maître de kung fu
remettre beaucoup plus influents c'est
beaucoup plus son mot à dire sur tous
les articles de maths que les autres et
selon les cas et au lycée elle a ce
pouvoir c'est parce qu'elle est très
active sur wikipédia est entendue il n'y
a pas juste savoir dans la personne qui
a joué il ya aussi le fait qu'elle soit
très active mais wikipédia reste une
forme moins faible débit stockera si à
mon sens puisque si elle n'avait pas
prouvé son expertise proposant des
modifications justifié justifiable
notamment source évoquant match wings et
pas forcément nécessaire de toujours
c'est si elle n'avait pas démontré son
expertise dans les propositions de
correction qu'elle avait fait très
certainement son influence aura été nul
et du coup elle aurait perdu pouvoir
d'édition parce qu'elle ne savait pas
assez et on cela utile médias et je
pense qu au moins partiellement et piste
au chrs indique enfin dans l'atteindre
up et nous fait remarquer que certaines
décisions vont nécessairement enfreindre
le principe de séparation des expertises
notamment lorsqu'il s'agit de voter des
budgets forcément un truc qui est
transdisciplinaires du coup faut trouver
une solution pour prendre ce genre de
décision ce genre de problème il se pose
bien sûr au niveau de tam il s'oppose
aussi au niveau toutes les universités
du monde qui cherchent à allouer
l'argent là où il faut recruter un
professeur du bouc domaine et à ce
moment il faut des expertises multiples
qu'il faut sans doute plus d'experts de
différents domaines qu'ils soient qu'ils
sont capables de coopérer de délibéré
c'est forcément des décisions plus
difficiles à prendre et plus difficile
sans doute de faire des pistes au cra 6
par rapport à cela
désiré ce que je pense que certaines
personnes sont bien plus à même
de réfléchir à ces questions que
l'électeur médian alors je sais c'est
surtout frustrant mais j'ai pas de
solution ultime pour tout ça il faut
essayer différentes solutions et si de
voir laquelle marche le mieux je pense
qu'il faut surtout prendre conscience
dans ce genre de questions très
difficiles de l'étendue de notre
ignorance et du coup je pense qu'il ya
encore beaucoup de recherches à faire
dans ce domaine
en tout cas je ne prétends absolument
pas avoir le fin mot de l'histoire tout
ce que j'ai essayé de dire dans les deux
vidéos précédentes c'est que pour ce
genre de décision peut-être que la
solution démocratique n'est pas la
meilleure elle espère que vous avez aimé
cette vidéo la prochaine fois on va tous
récapituler ça va être la dernière vidéo
de la série sur la démocratie est alors
du coup pour la prochaine série qu'est
ce qui va se passer a malheureusement
fait pas de bonne réponse à vous donner
pour l'instant parce que ça dépend de
d'autres projets secrets sur les lieux
de travail
du coup va falloir patienter il est
possible qu'on passe une petite période
de 100 vidéo malheureusement parce que
si j'ai beaucoup de travail en ce moment
un petit peu débordé mais quoi qu'il
arrive je vous promets que la prochaine
série sera vraiment trop cool encore
vous avez aimez cette vidéo pensez y
répliquer à la commentaire partagé
pensez à vous abonner pour n'augmenter
épisode merci aux anticorps de leurs
dons et j'espère que vous serez là la
prochaine fois aujourd'hui les enfants
sont hyper connectés ils ont tous accès
à internet très jeune ne serait ce que
sur leur smartphone ils sont de très
gros consommateurs d absurdité de
youtube parfois trash ou gore parfois
sexy pour racoleur parfois xénophobes ou
misogyne
ap